[Music]
BMA fashion is always unexpected and
crazy ET is breaking down the fierce
fabulous and wildest looks of the night
[Music]
cardi be looked stunning on her first
red carpet since giving birth to
daughter culture wearing custom-made
Nicholas Gibran her velvet fuchsia
Couture dress features a single sleeved
off-the-shoulder design with a high slit
fashion sure is Shawn Mendes was dapper
as ever in a classic Navy and hunter
green Paul Smith's suit while the video
Vanguard honoree Jennifer Lopez made
jaws drop in all Versace all night for
both her silver ensemble on the pink
carpet and her golden performance outfit
Kylie Jenner supported her man Travis
Scott and though the couple walked the
carpet solo
Kylie turned heads in this white Tom
Ford blazer dress and al gana Paris
shoes Shay Mitchell looked tan and toned
in an orange embroidered mini dress with
long sleeves and a plunging draped
neckline also by Nicolas Gibran Nicki
Minaj rocked one of the wildest looks of
the night in this virgil ablo autumn
winter 2018 collection cream bodysuit
with black pipe lining under a tulle
skirt pairing the look with a matching
choker and belt as she won the best hip
hop award for her song chun-li and Amber
Rose arrived in an Allred risque
ensemble which she explained to ET ahead
of the show
you look like your intergalactic space
[ __ ]
[Music]